I'm Nicola Zara and I'm president and
founder of zo design
well I I make games more fun so I'm the
leading expert on emotion in front of
games and I work with companies everyone
from EA to Sony to Ubisoft to play first
to make their games more engaging I
essentially for the past 20 years I've
studied how to make the screen you know
more more engaging
oh there's been an enormous amount
changes which has been really really
rewarding because back in the year 2000
sort of at the turn of this century I
had this revelation on top of a temple
in Egypt I was standing on the temple
and Andara looking out over the desert
was a hot day and I reached down for my
canteen to get that last sip of water
when they're my feet someone had carved
a game board and I thought wow you know
two people had stood where I stood and
thought to pass the time of the game and
I wondered what were their feelings what
were their emotions what engage them in
that activity you know 2,000 years ago
and then what would they think of how
they respond to the games we played
today then putting on my future hat
thinking about what kinds of engagement
what kinds of games we play say in the
year 2020 and it was then that I noticed
that the the kinds of game experiences
that I wanted to have were were going to
have to with the industry was going to
have to go through significant a number
of changes to capture that same amount
of play and engagement in a sense that
set me on this train of research for the
past 10 years to look at what creates
why people play games and what makes
games fun because if you think about it
sort of like Newton watching the Apple
fall in emotions have this invisible
pull on human action and its present if
you see you in any kind of any kind of
game play but if you look at the games
that that I work on in the industry they
have thousands of rules and maybe a
handful of emotions but if you look at a
group of kids playing you know you see
the whole pantheon the entire pantheon
of human emotions coming from a game
with a single rule you have tag you're
it so it's been really wonderful of the
past year ten years to share with that
the game industry hundreds and hundreds
and thousands of people who downloaded
our white papers and research to look at
the the whole spectrum of games evolving
so we've saw the entrance of a lot of a
lot of mechanics of easy fun with the we
you know that exploration and roleplay
we've got new kinds of games that are
both educational and and and good for
you in a sense so there's a lot of brain
age and you know people playing dance
dance revolution to lose weight people
playing eco games now to you know make
the world a better place and then social
gaming is huge right is a huge trend and
we see that
something we call people fun that where
people really experience more emotions
the more that they connect through
gameplay and so that's a really
interesting trend so we've seen
essentially the industry go from what
was very a very small percentage of the
whole population roughly about fifteen
percent this hardcore market we're now
starting finally to see the games jump
the chasm to a more of a mass-market
product so if you know the across in the
chasm by mouth Malcolm Gladwell that you
get these new kinds of new kinds of
players entering the market space they
want different products they want
different kinds of interaction and so
now that's what we're seeing with the
games games being produced by give
companies like playfish and Zynga and
you know plate of these the Mafia Wars
of the world the farmville of the world
all of those are really helping people
engage in social interaction it's that
social interaction that they actually
enjoy more than the game itself in fact
if you see people play at you in the
same room you'll see more emotions wide
variety emotions more intense emotions
than people playing the same game in
different rooms and so what we're
helping our clients do is take those you
know multiplayer interactions that might
happen in the real world to put them
into game mechanics that make you know
online play you all that much more
engaging
when I was inspired to do is to really d
down into what makes things fun you know
why do we play games so what I did was I
looked across across across games so I
studied everything from Halo to Tetris
people playing at home school and work
young and old all the platforms
cross-gender and I noticed that there
were a lot of similarities between what
the favorite the people players favorite
moments and games were and so what I did
is I collected those moments on
videotape and then I used Paul Ekman
facial action coding simplified it 4
games to measure their emotional
responses so there's seven emotions you
can measure in the face others you can
measure in the body and when I did so I
took those favorite moments and games
into the cluster analysis it turns out
that the group into you know for roughly
categories of emotion and then looking
at those emotions I looked at well what
were the similarities of the types of
decisions players were making what kinds
of play styles what kind of play
mechanics were involved and that's how
we carry them up with the four keys to
fund so that's our model with
essentially that's basically the
research says that games create
engagement essentially four ways there's
the hard phone of challenge and mastery
the frustration that leads to what we
call fier of thanks i won you know be
where you get the boss monster there's
this wonderful feeling in the body
that's on personal accomplishment you
know usability and making things easy to
use won't get you there at that emotion
at all in fact you have to feel
frustrated and so frustrated right ready
to throw the control to the window if
then at that point you win that's when
you get that feeling like yes we really
did it very very powerful emotion if
players will play hours of games both
hardcore and casual gamers will play
hours to get that that kind of feeling
and then we notice that well it wasn't
just about the points and scoring you're
like basketball it's fun to shoot you
know it's fun to shoot hoops for score
but it's also just fun to just shoot
hoops right you know it wouldn't be fun
if the basketball hoop were like this
big you know it you know it's nice that
it's that small right and so it makes it
makes it more challenging but players
also like other things like just
dribbling the ball is fun or playing
without a score and so there's this easy
fun that goes along with the hard fun so
there's a hard fun a challenge in
mastery the easy funders more about
exploration and roleplay storytelling we
get mechanics involving ambiguity and
detail so in the sims you know you can
put the sims in your pool and then pull
out the ladders to see what happens
you can drive a race track backwards in
Grand Theft Auto you can go from point A
to point B on a mission the hard front
of the game right but at any point in
time you can actually also they give you
like I'm improv theatre they give you a
plate glass window they give you a
freeway exit ramp parking meters and
it's up to you as the player to figure
out how those how those interact and so
with that that kind of mechanic we
really they're very different type of
they're very different types of
interactions that were going but we
noticed is that with the four keys is
that best-selling games tend to have
three out of the four and players
wouldn't do just one they tended to also
within a 20-minute session have three
out of the four that they played and
their favorites were three out of you
know roughly three out of four so that's
hard fun for our station of here that's
easy fun with curiosity Wonder and
surprise wonders this great emotion that
actually adults feel very rarely so
that's wonderfully games and movies you
know can give it give it to us but games
especially then the third one is what we
call serious fun so in easy fun you get
a lot of feedback for you know car plate
glass window see what happens in serious
fun it's actually all about the reward
so how do you feel before during and
after so we find players play to blow
off frustration at their boss or at
their teacher they also play though for
you know getting the feeling of getting
smarter or of you know creating
something you're making a difference in
the world there is people playing again
brain age to lose weight Dance Dance
Revolution to you know I'm sorry brain
age to get smarter and dance dance
revolution to lose weight but we also
see stuff that really represents who
they are so there's a lot of there's
about to be a real surgeon eco games
which we're actually making making one
which we can talk about in a bit that
this our game our game taupe and that's
the allows players to express their
values in the world so it's not just
about playing games separate but
actually how it reflects on them and
what they value what they what their
what their motives what their motives
are what they what they like about and
want amanha see happen so that's serious
fun that's excitement and relaxation a
lot of other motions repetition rhythm
you know music didn't get into that the
we're using the fun of games to do real
work often serious game and where you're
doing a firefighting simulator or you
know a nuclear you know power plant
simulator to learn that's all part of
serious fun and then the last form of
engage
it is people fun and people fund is
really it's amazing area you've got
emotionally motion that we can measure
is amusement so laughter so you can
laugh in whenever you see laughter then
you know that you're getting people to
engage with each other and with people
fun we have a lot of mechanics or social
mechanics that create social bonding
that bring people together everyone's
got a friend for example that can make
you do the roll on the floor laughing
thing right and when you can actually
then get up and breathe again you
actually feel closer to that person and
so what's interesting about that is that
there's not a disconnect between I mean
it actually it actually doesn't separate
the game doesn't separate it actually
pulls people together and what we get
there is we get on the ability to
actually create social bonds I really
hate the word social capital a lot of
folks in the social media space talk
about oh well we're building social
capital when in fact what you're really
doing is you're weaving social the
social fabric between between people so
some of the factors that go into it are
creating social tokens for example so if
you have mechanics in your game that
could then be mutated or change in a
certain way and pass from player to
player that can actually increase the
social the social bond goes on the game
so if I give you a health pack I feel
generous you feel gratitude and then you
know someone else might feel see that
that actions Oh elevation Wow human
kindness and then later on the game you
know that that that situation may be
reversed or you might explore experience
schadenfreude which is you know you the
pleasure when someone you in one of your
rivals you know experiences misfortune
or nacos which is this pleasure and
pride when someone you help succeeds so
you mentor someone and they succeed you
feel this emotion around them so do you
think about we can do just by adding
these different verbs adding new verbs
to the games we can actually change what
we call it a motion profile so just like
wine or chocolate has this flavor
profile you know you have a nose and
head and a nice long finish games and
other entertainment produce a series of
sensations in the body that can be
intentionally designed they already
create and even media products other
media products create social media for
example creates certain have certain
emotional signatures in the body if you
will and you can actually intentionally
design them to create to create
different things that really go with the
the task at hand so for example the
social media platforms like
Facebook and Twitter all of them have a
number of different verbs that really
match the really match this this profile
of friendship and getting closer so for
example the best-selling games on
facebook you know are the ones that how
are about you know people plants and and
people plans and pets okay and all those
have wonderful social emotions you know
mafias you know you've got farmville you
know gardening and you've got you know
pet society or you know the animal you
know animal crossing kind of clones and
all of those are really revolve around
friendship you also have verbs so the
verb in facebook of poke you know so
that by adding that feature poke that
kind of is like well that's a poke in
the ribs maybe so that's friendly so he
creates a little bit what we call a
miche you know this it's Italian for
this friendly you know friendly kind of
feeling but what we can do is with that
is you can then actually by adding these
verbs or taking them out you can adjust
this this emotion emotion profile same
thing with Twitter so Twitter actually
has a very a very challenged board right
now because it's gotta follow you follow
me kind of game going on so you have
underneath your avatar Photo you've
created a game because by putting that
hard fun that score how many followers I
have underneath my own raise my head
shot well that kind of encourages
certain behavior cuz people won't behave
to maximize that score because that's
that's what score does right so what you
do then is friend as many people who
then friend you back and so then your
score goes up but then what happens to
your feed of your following if you're
following you know a million people are
you really following any of them can you
really use it to you know you know stay
up there really touch base with them or
is it just you know a lot of people have
you know zero tweets and you know a
thousand followers it's like well what's
that all about it's not in so in a sense
that by putting a score their players
actually broke the game to broke the
game a little bit and so the ad addition
of lists and obviously you know some
other mechanics like retweeting and
dming and stuff direct messaging and
stuff that all helps bind the bind that
buying the game by the game the game
that is Twitter find that social
experience together so you can see how
all these these actions create have a
sense a cloud of emotion around them and
that's what makes the experience really
fill out just like a film would with
story and character we're actually
painting in a sense to you I if it were
actually painting the experience with
emotion
and attention and your sucha you can buy
an attention son you can actually color
it any any emotion that you choose if
you know what what verb to use
well i think that the experiences that
are being designed are definitely much
more casual in our research what's
interesting is that it's not so much the
mechanic the type of choice that you
make in the game or the type of
challenge but the theme tends to have
more of a gender of a gender skew what's
interesting with that I'm glad you
brought up the gender issue because
there's some really interesting stuff
not every not all guys want to have a
Rambo fantasy some kind of get tired of
it after a little while a lot of guys
like it like sports but not everybody
likes to likes like sports and if you
think about what if you get two groups
and it could be Jeb divided by gender or
age you know average set certain time
amount of violence in the experience you
have to remember that that average is an
average of what well it's an average of
individuals and those individuals
actually aren't all on that same line
even there's a if there's a statistical
difference between the two you actually
then have to normal distribution curves
and so there's a lot of guys in the
girls range site and a lot of girls in
the guys range and what people tend to
forget with the with 50 years of
marketing experience behind us now we
tend to jump right into the gender is
like oh this is a defining rule this is
how we make our games medics we're going
to target this by gender turns out
though if we put everything that people
like about games we just sort of dumped
it on the table okay and then one hand
we gather everything that guys like and
only guys like in one hand if we gather
the other hand everything girls like an
only women like in the other well then
we do what do we do will the game
industry well it makes a game for guys
and a game for girls right well what are
we forgetting turns out what we're
forgetting is everything that's still on
the table right and it turns out in
terms of our research everything that's
still in the table is what players like
the most about games and so when we
think about how to you know use use use
gender segmentation as a way to make
games more fun it's actually a pretty
slippery slope because if you're looking
at a lot of games that are have mass
appeal you know it's like 40-60 you know
male and female and so end games are all
almost all played in mixed gendered
environments so it's not surprising that
the most popular games like World of
Warcraft or the sims or mist we've
worked on three of them is series is
that they actually a draw they actually
draw from both pools you know there's
mechanics and situations and the--
that appeal to that appeal to both but
in terms of casual games what we find is
that there's a lot of very interesting
obviously themed stuff so the whole the
restaurant restaurant simulations diner
dash we've worked with plate play first
on everything since standard edge to
pretty much on as you come through our
lab and what we've noticed is that there
are a number of of mechanics and it's
not that they women women absolutely
like hard fun you might think that oh
it's the guys I want the real sweaty
kind of like intense experience the
girls want this either very social or
very easy time not true at all I mean
women love as well as meant they really
love to work hard for their game the
more the harder they work the more
rewarding it feels and so it's not
surprising that people will you play
Tetris on time mode and it's even where
you work up you do work up a sweat but
what we don't see is we don't see a lot
of complexity in the controls so you
know women do tend to invest less time
in learning and a saying they also are
newer entrance into the market so it
correlates a lot more with casual and
core kind of games is like you know how
long you been playing games and how
often you play because games for the
hardcore market have really scaled up in
terms of adding additional features over
time and the hardcore market really is
perfected you know the sort of five core
games there's five core games that they
perfected whereas the casual spaces is
much more is as much more open
till tues game in basically it's flips
adventure in 1.5 dimensions and it's an
experience on the iphone what we we've
done is the story starts with flip who
crawls out of this polluted ooze that
was once Shady Glen and decides to take
on this toxic green black cloud by
eating carbon out of the air and
gathering water and seeds to replant the
forest and flip was just a tiny little
lizardy you know kind of froggy
chameleon kind of character and can
really only move and you know in four
directions so it can only only have four
positions and what we did was we created
this so all you do too there are no
buttons in the game all you do is tilt
the game that you just tilt the iphone
to to control it and flip gathers you
know water and seeds and eats east
pollution and what we found is that we
wanted to really capitalize on or give
people the opportunity to express
themselves kind of like the powers of
ten video if you've seen that Eames
animation where you go from really small
to be like way out towards Saturn and
then go back down again and we wanted to
have the give players the experience of
the power of tiny actions so if I just
you know to make it simple choice
between say paper and plastic you know
today or I turn off my light switch then
you actually those those you want to see
how those decisions add up to a global
experience of play and so we've got a
single player layer for the game where
you go through 12 scenes or 60 levels to
the game and then you can all of your
tilt points or geocoded to where you
earn them so we can actually have on a
global scale we can have different
continents and different regions you
know competing and cooperating against
each other so we have you know North
America going against China and then in
the real world we take it one step
further where you can actually take do
an action in the real world like you
change your light bulbs and you or you
know you might use your reduce your
carbon footprint or you know to insert a
recycling program or an educational
program and if you were to share that
with on social media with your friends
with a tag for the game the game will
actually scrape that and you earn credit
for in the game so you can basically do
stuff in the real world and through the
miracle of social media you actually do
better in the in the game so we take it
all the way up to that to to a real
world experience to make the world a
better place and it's all through all
through gameplay
the iphone is taking gaming to a whole
nother level of play because it's always
with you it's always with you and there
are a lot of new sensors so you have
accelerometer and geo geo coding that
sort of thing and more importantly i
think is it's also social and so that
social interaction that through gameplay
because it has your contact list on for
example you know being able to bridge
out to your friends and play together in
these micropayments of time if you will
it's going to be a huge thing for the
iphone even i said i say this even
though i invented the very first game to
use the accelerometer the very first
version of tilt i designed with joe
hewitt at I phone dev camp about a week
after the iphone came out and we it was
really fun because we just had to web
pages one YouTube video and yet we got
250,000 visits because we mapped the
mechanics of the game into the new
control set of the iphone and also it
created that sense of wonder that
curiosity wondered surprise and when
people who had an iphone they didn't
have an app store no api or is like that
so they could play they could play with
the things that came on the device but
if they hopped over to our webpage they
could have a whole new experience to
show to their friends there's a lot of
over-the-shoulder play as well and so
you know just for wrapping back in what
we've got is this whole new whole new
set of games and it's not just the
control it's not just the micro format
that fits in your hand but it's that
connectedness and the fact that i can
asynchronously play with my friends
again to sort of weave more social
fabric with them that's what's going to
be the real the real killer app if you
will you know for the for the iphone and
in fact you know with the new linearly
announced ipad i predict that eve eating
isn't going to be the dominant you know
meeting your newspapers not going to be
the dominant use its use case at all the
dominant thing is actually going to be
gaming and two player gaming though i
don't think many people will you know
hold that device that's that large you
know in front of them her for that long
to say drive a car what will happen
though is I could put it down you know
in between us and then we have a then we
have a game board between us and then
kind of like that Star Wars chest seen
you know in episode three or whatever
you can actually make moves and we can
share that invite or we have it in our
lap and we have this battleship kind
experience where I can see some of your
screen but not that's going to be four
time we're going to real face-to-face
electronic gaming I can't wait we're
going to be obviously taking tilt to the
ipad and i can't wait to see what
developers come up with
what our mission right now is you know
with launching tilt and the consulting
that we do with our client companies is
really unlocking you know human
potential and improving quality of life
through Play and it's not I mean there
isn't a game in the world that doesn't
teach and there's no play style even
that doesn't teach so there is this very
human not not not a human need but I
mean it's a human it's just a human
facility this this play experience is
part of what we do so we're actually
going to see work and play get a lot
closer a lot closer together so we're
going to be playing more at work we're
actually going to be you know we're
actually going to have work that feels
more like like play so I predict that
not only do we have we're going to have
more robust enough simulations training
simulation games you know so if I you
know if I hand you a nuclear reactor you
know you can you can you can you can you
can play with it you can you can train
do you do management training that way
you can do all kinds of social in fact
you know worlds of warcraft if you're a
little guild leader you know you're
learning a lot about management managing
other people so i think we're going to
see a lot of stuff happening in in in
games coming through and i think I'm
really hopeful for is why I'm sharing a
lot my research is that what we're
really hopeful for is to see huge
changes in the American you know in the
American workplace and you know actually
all around the world because when I go
in and I'm you know I'm trained to read
emotion on people's faces what I see and
I see that and I see their work styles
and there you know what tasks they can
actually do and you know I'm in awe and
in horror of what I see when I go into
the average office space because the
work there is so I mean it's so ill
suited to the task at hand you know if
this were a zoo or a kindergarten you
know Child Protective Services or you
know the humane society would be there
down there you know to close it down
about an hour because the the work
environment that the physical space the
types of tasks the emotions around those
tasks are totally ill suited to
accomplishing the task at hand and so by
unreal understanding play what motivates
people and games are self-motivating
systems so self-motivating systems we're
going to see that self-motivation
permeate throughout everything from word
processing to you know the way that your
copier operates we're going to see not
only that we're going to see these game
mechanics you
embedded in embedded in the software
that we use you know in the physical
devices that we touch like you know a
copy machine will also see it in this
business structures as well so we're
going to see the way that we give
feedback the way that we give out tasks
the way that we manage folks is actually
going to be a lot more responsive 22
game style kind of thinking because in a
game what do you have to have well Sid
Meier says it's got to be interesting
choices right so you got to have that
but then you also you know I think that
what we do in games we really we
simplify the world you know we suspend
some consequences you know that gives us
a little free action and then we then
enhance the feedback and enhancing the
feedback and enhancing the reward that
easy phone and that that serious fun
really can then motivate folks motivate
people to explore and extend themselves
and if they when they accomplish
something hard they could do before then
that hard fun comes in and you feel much
more well-rounded as a person and much
more much more you know you feel much
more sent that sense of accomplishment
and you know really usefulness you know
in in society as large and actually just
riffing off of that a bit I think that
also the other way the games are
changing the way we are as a society is
that games have multi-variant inputs so
especially simulation games so you've
got multiple things coming in and you
have the ability to to to make a lot of
changes so in a sense simulation games
are really have the opportunity to
change the world to really educate us as
global citizens because what our
simulation games are they are a they
have multivariate inputs and
multivariant outputs so when I play
simcity I play a city manager and I you
make decisions you know and I can make
decisions yet related to Godzilla or I
can make decisions to earthquake or fire
or I can you build it up but when you're
done with the same city you actually
know a little bit more about that you
know a little more that world and what
do we need what we really need right now
are people who can understand
multi-variant systems to fight things
like global warming aids all of these
problems we've pretty much dealt with a
lot of the low-hanging fruit here and so
you know i think the games play a really
serious role really important role in
elevating up our thinking to that next
level of play and i think if we can do
that the world will definitely be a
better place
growing up as a kid one of my favorite
wanted as a kid the thing that dropped
had me drop the most quarters was Star
Wars the star was fights him I love the
the feeling of flying I love that that
whole experience I felt like I was this
you know fighter pilot and I was you
know racing and I never got past level
seven but you know I love the way the
audio came in i was in that universe
even though it was only wireframe at the
time there's a wireframe kind of you
know flight sim and that that that
experience allowed me to extend my love
of the whole Star Wars universe which
again was this you know this fan at this
aspirational fantasy so it really
connected it you know yo for me and I
think that would be yeah that would
definitely be my favorite game